[Music]
[Applause]
peter schrager nfl network good morning
football co-host and good morning
football live from l.a for super bowl
week starting on monday at 7 00 a.m
eastern peter
how would you recap the week for
somebody who didn't let's say somebody
was out of the country didn't know what
happened
and you said hey what happened in the
nfl how would you recap it
to the biggest long shot in nfl history
to make the super bowl made super bowl
on sunday tom brady retired on a tuesday
and before he could even get his
bouquets uh one of the nfl coaches sued
the nfl and two nfl football teams over
uh systematic racism and hiring
practices and that was just the start of
the week and now we've had further that
we've had some different coaching hires
we've had some other controversies it is
the nfl we're living in right now and i
don't think any of it should uh
should
should be be mentioned without saying
that hey the florist thing should be
number one number two number three and
yet the way the nfl works it's like all
right the super bowl's on next week and
i don't know if it's still going to be
top of mind because that's how fast the
news cycle works yeah i agree uh adam
schefter tweeted the niners offensive
coordinator mike mcdaniel arrived in
south florida last night for his head
coaching interview with the dolphins
cowboys offensive coordinator kellen
moore scheduled for his head coaching
interview with the dolphins on saturday
how attractive is that dolphins job
right now
yeah i could tell you that that i know
for mike's case he definitely wants the
job it's a chance to be an nfl head
coach and
you know that's the point it's a lot of
these guys
they still want these jobs because how
do i know i'm ever going to get another
opportunity to get in there so if you're
a mike mcdaniel or kellen moore and yes
you are walking into a situation where
the last coach and the owner and the gm
um obviously had conflict and there's an
ongoing lawsuit and all this
but hey here's mike mcdaniel he's been
in the league since 2005. he's a 40 year
old guy he's he's been waiting his time
too and he's like i i want to go for it
this is my job opportunity and i would
love to be the head coach of the miami
dolphins so he didn't withdraw his name
from that i could tell you that that
interview is 12 45 today is when he's
going to be interviewing with the
dolphins they are going to also
interview kellen moore so the decision
won't be made today but those are the
two names i'm hearing right now and no
neither one of them are people of color
it's mike mcdaniel boy wonder offensive
coach and it's kellen moore who's even
younger offensive coach
and
you know i know the optics aren't great
for the nfl but that is what has been
the case going right up from minnesota
where it's harbaugh or kevin o'connell
to jacksonville where it seemed like at
the last second it was either doug
peterson or rich versace so
we've got a couple teams left texans and
saints we'll see if if their hires do
satisfy um what i think is a great great
need for you know african-american and
people of color to be head coaches in
the nfl i was wondering doug peterson
got the jacksonville job do we know if
byron leftwich was offered the job
do you not know that yeah i know that
don't don't know if it got to that point
i know that they were very interested
in nathaniel hackett and he chose the
denver job and that kind of made them
restart their whole thing what's
interesting with that one is it breaks
last night either adam schefter ian
rapport one of the insiders breaks it
and it happens
around 10 o'clock eastern and all right
everyone does their whole thing here's
what peterson who didn't they hire
they fired urban meyer in week 14 of the
nfl season they interviewed doug
peterson on december 28th they were
radio silent they did not reach out to
doug peterson and have a second
interview
until february 4th
i don't know what happened in those 40
days in between but i don't remember a
coaching uh hire ever as drawn out and
go so many twists and turns than what
the jaguars did the first candidate to
interview in week 16 of the nfl season
or week right after the nfl season was
doug peterson um and then they
interviewed about 20 guys in between and
then eventually hired doug peterson
bizarre but if you look at the the uh
the openings here in the offseason the
worst
opening was where i know everybody wants
to be a head coach but the worst opening
is which team or was the next team
there's nine openings a lot of those
teams fire head coaches because of the
situations that they're in um
see the worst might also be with the
greatest potential to build and i think
the team in the most questionable
situation right now is the houston
texans because they don't have that
quarterback that they necessarily
thought would be the correct now is
davis mills that guy i don't know he had
a nice finish of the season
um but they are so
raw and so barren as far as just talent
on the roster and then with no real
direction of what they're going to be
new gm and nick casario new president
and jack easterby and there's a hope
that they make the right hire and they
can build something there but you want
to talk about an uphill battle going
into houston right now without any real
thing to hang your hat on it's certainly
something that is from the ground zero
of building an nfl team talking to peter
schrager nfl network good morning
football co-host and
foxsports.com senior national writer the
show will be in los angeles next week
starting uh 7 a.m eastern
i talked to a former tv executive last
night and i said if you were
still involved in this would you offer
tom brady a job as an analyst
and he said if i'm amazon
i just i put it out there that will give
you 25 million dollars a year
and see if tom would want to be an
analyst
you know let's say with uh
al michaels
what do you think of that
yeah i mean that's i don't know if money
is what motivated this guy ever though
that's the problem it's like
you could dangle a lot of money in front
of tom brady it's never been what has
been his main motivation and you could
say that he's made enough himself his
wife made enough in her career like i i
think the manning situation truly makes
the future of all these broadcasters
interesting like
you know drew brees did the playoff game
and gotten you know blasted everywhere
because they thought that he wasn't
interesting enough and he had to you
know check his phone and just say this
guy's terrible jason whitten same thing
meanwhile the mannings are sitting on
their couch
and they're interviewing their friends
and doing it on their terms and i think
tom brady is one of the few athletes
that could say
i actually want to do it xyz way and i
don't want to do it going on the road
and being in cincinnati to call a
raiders bengals game where i can be
criticized by joe schmoe on the on the
couch for how good i am at calling this
um
i suggested that you get gronk and brady
and you could have your own you know
bradycast here
that's not bad i i think that's
interesting and it's on brady's terms as
long as brady can dictate where and how
it does i don't think i see tom brady
wanting to call week 13
you know broncos chargers in denver
because he's got you know romo missed
the day after thanksgiving this year i
think he missed that sunday and people
went nuts like he's making how much
money how could he miss a game
guys these guys they do have a lot of
power in these buildings i think brady
would have the ultimate power if he were
to choose to work with one of these
networks i got tony dungy next hour
and i want to ask him how do we fix the
rooney rule or update the rooney like
but if it's not a tweak
or is it an overhaul and what
suggestions would he have because the
rooney rule came out when tony got fired
and i think um
trying to think who else
there were two black coaches who got
fired at the same time and i think
that's when we had the rooney rule that
that came about what do you think tony
would suggest on how to modify this
and we had chris carter on good morning
football today very very
vocal in in the situation that the nfl
head coaching
world is in right now and you know i
said well they've tried to do like
financial incentives with draft picks
and all that and i i think the problem
is way way
way more in the weeds than just a can we
meet with these guys
i think it starts with with preparing
young african-american assistants to be
nfl head coaches so it's not enough to
just have a a african-american defensive
quarter it's saying okay let's let's get
you every possible thing that you need
so that you could walk in that room and
you don't feel like you're up against it
and you don't feel like you're walking
into a sham interview that you can wow
them and you could also just say hey
look at the tape and check my references
i shouldn't have to razzle and dazzle
and do something any differently than
any of the counterparts so i'm
interviewing with i look at there are so
many
great young assistant coaches in the
league right now and so few of them got
opportunities to interview for those
head coaching jobs i think that's the
issue it's not just getting someone in
the room it's it's saying hey let's
recognize these young assistants and
let's groom them so that they're getting
the hype and buzz that kellen moore's
getting at age 30 that they're getting
the hype and buzz that shawn mcveigh got
at age 30.
you know you could name the young
assistant coach that you like i look at
sean mcvay's assistant head coach and
he's a running backs coach right now in
in in los angeles i've gotten to know
thomas brown really well
this guy is a former georgia bulldogs
running back beloved by the players
uh is is a huge asset to sean mcvay and
yet he was mentioned for the miami
dolphins head coaching job briefly how
come he didn't get to interview for nine
jobs where
jonathan gannon who is going to be
considered for all these jobs the
defensive coordinator of an eagles team
that lost in the wild card round i just
think it's not enough to just say hey
we're going to give you you know x y and
z an opportunity to interview i think it
really starts at a young age 28 29 30
identifying people who aren't just
assistant coaches but want to be head
coaches and saying let's not only
prepare them for that but let's prepare
the rest of the league and give them
opportunities to have the same
networking that some of the white young
assistant coaches have had yeah that's
well put if you had one question for the
commissioner next week what would the
question be
one question for the commissioner my
question would probably revolve around
what was brought to light here and the
same question you just asked me same
question you brought to tony dungy
clearly the rooney rule is not merely
enough what else can we do and how else
can we actually
do that with action and not just words
and i would love to think that there are
answers there and that there is not only
the commissioner
but every single person who is employed
by the nfl and working with the nfl who
is noticing what's going on in this
hiring cycle and says hey here's my
input here my two cents and that's a
collaborative effort in the decisions
that are made moving forward dennis
green was the other coach who was fired
i think the same time 2002
when tony was fired and then they
brought about the rooney rule
how would you uh sum up joe burrows
month
coolest kid in the world hey like what
are you talking about
i i love the fact that his high school
stadium is already named after him like
it's like it's like everyone who knows
the guy knows the guy all the lsu people
love him i went to the game last week
chief's uh
chiefs bengals and obviously it was all
chiefs fans but there were pockets of
bengals fans and the amount of lsu
borough fans who saw it i would go to
the very ellis you fan you a bengals fan
i'm a joe burrow fan i'm like alright
that's pretty cool this guy's the man
and
i i don't know i don't know if they've
got it what it takes to go in as a team
with one player with super bowl
experience and beat the rams in their
building
but i don't know if there's another
quarterback in the league i'd want to
have the ball going into that situation
than joe burrow right now yeah and i i
asked peter king last hour he said you
got an mvp vote if we were taking the
vote after the super bowl and the
bengals one he said
joe burrow would be the mvp
maybe it's him even if they lose the
fact that you get the bengal
he gave hope to every franchise or he
put every franchise on notice like hey
this guy got his team to the super bowl
they got sacked nine times in a win
against the raiders like uh
pretty amazing um you know this meteoric
rise from you know national championship
heisman trophy second year going to the
super bowl heady stuff man
it really is and the stuff that he did
last week that isn't going to be
glorified until maybe we do all the film
work and the off season like all those
third downs where chris jones had him
and he just slides away and he scrambles
away it's like so symbolic of this team
because they were down 24 points to the
chargers they came all the way back they
lost they were down two touchdowns to
the 49ers they came all the way back
they lost they were back in that game
with the packers that they lost even
their losses it was like he was a
cockroach like you could not put joe
burrow down he found a way to claw back
and everything and now it's just
clicking i couldn't give any more and
like i said on good morning football
today there everyone and their mother
has a podcast now everyone and their
mother thinks you know i work for a
gambling site i do this i i'm working on
this analytics page like literally there
are eight billion people doing sports
media and nine million talking heads who
just dilution no one took the bengals
before this season not a soul i think
that's pretty cool you're an ohio guy
you got to appreciate that oh i do
but i i'm i'm not rooting as much as
those fans deserve this those you know
my i'm actually rooting for my friends
and family because whenever you would
say you were from cincinnati
inevitably you would get the following
oh the bungles always always so to get
there to be proud you got your
quarterback you got your wide receiver
you got a good running back
i go back to september where we thought
their head coach may get fired like you
know that's how crazy this season's been
um i'll leave you with this or if you
can leave me with this
the cool spots for us to go in los
angeles i mean you know what's going on
yeah i'll give you the list here you go
okay number one is number one is craig's
it's the old mater d from santana's he's
got a spot now this is where i saw on
tmz that kanye and
someone else was there so that must be
cool i'm told delilah is the hot club
guys like us will will not be allowed in
necessarily but that is where people go
and the last one is a little place that
my guy walker hayes sings so beautifully
about it's a little restaurant called
applebee's and that is where i will
probably be most nights getting my
chicken fingers or mozzarella sticks
uh does walker hayes know that he ruined
cbs's halftime show i thought i thought
just the opposite i thought that those
guys were talking over walker hayes and
i found that obnoxious
what do i need to hear i need to hear
nate burleson saying that they need to
establish the run give me the walker
hayes
what is boomer assistant saying in that
segment that i need to hear yeah
[Laughter]
oh that's great peter thank you and uh
hopefully we'll cross paths with you in
l.a
i would love to see you guys you got the
best show still dan i appreciate you
having me on that's peter schrager nfl
network good morning co-host